what's up guys Jared here to talk about
the most buzz worthy cinematic
contribution of 2019 just kidding I
obviously mean Joker now we expected
that a film spotlighting comic book
lures most iconic supervillain would
crush at the box office but what we
didn't expect was that the director of
The Hangover Part 2 would be so central
to the political zeitgeist but one of
the most interesting things about Joker
is that while it clearly resonated
strongly in 2019 so much of the film
borrows from past cinematic traditions
and when you parse through the copious
references from film history you'll find
that they're all drawing from
approximately the same time period that
is the mid 1970s to early 80s that's not
us being evil geniuses Todd Phillips has
said as much it was really a group of
movies and a time of movies so so I
would almost argue that as movies from
1973 to 1981
there's a ton of movies that influenced
this film quick caveats
because saying the phrase movies made
between 1973 to 1981 a takes forever and
B is boring we're just gonna broadly
refer to this time period as 70 cinema
so forgive us for the slight fudging now
the 70s were an objectively cool and
complex time for movies and we're
constantly reppin the era in our videos
still we've been wondering why is Joker
so preoccupied with this era of
filmmaking let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on references in Joker
and major spoilers ahead for a film that
you and a hundred million other people
have already seen also older movies like
taxi driver and the king of comedy so
let's dive in Phillips's 70s vibe is
evident in every frame of the film from
the gritty establishing shots of Gotham
to the Impressionist ik angles of
Joaquin's interpretive dancing but that
inspiration also manifests pretty
heavily in the movies themes which is
what we're gonna be focusing on today
now Phillips vision board is so crowded
with themes from this era ranging from
class conflict to the cult of celebrity
that we could be chatting until the
inevitable Joker sequel arrives in
theaters so in the interest of not
missing happy hour
we picked the three we find most
interesting part
one bad guys in 1970s the anti-hero
reigned supreme an antihero is basically
a morally ambiguous protagonist who
would probably sell out their own mother
for a decent old-fashioned now the 70s
were deep in the era of new Hollywood a
period that began in the mid 1960s and
was defined by bulldog tour directors
like Robert Altman Francis Ford Coppola
and Stanley Kubrick these guys in their
cohorts made daring films like medium
cool Dog Day Afternoon taxi driver five
Easy Pieces Harold and Maude Annie Hall
American Graffiti
and so on according to scholar David
Thompson while films of the previous
decade featured naive and liberal
revolutionary notions and harnessed the
eras optimistic energy films of the
early 70s became confounded by actual
experiences that showed the moral
bankruptcy of the established order yes
you don't have to be a film scholar to
see why movies turned grimly cynical
this time period was basically defined
by post Vietnam War despair and anger at
the establishment in 1972 that cocktail
of misery was coupled with outrage over
Watergate and ensuing disillusionment
with the government by 1974 just 36% of
Americans trusted the government that
meant movies about flawed broken worlds
and deeply cynical characters fittingly
that also meant the rise of the antihero
or that almost always male protagonist
who is complex and deeply flawed
sometimes beyond the point of redemption
these characters make shocking morally
ambiguous choices from taxi drivers
Travis Bickle who commits a heinous ly
violent act to save a child victim of
sex trafficking to the king of comedies
Rupert Pupkin who takes a famous
comedian hostage in order to score some
decent airtime for his own stand-up act
- Dog Day Afternoon Sonny worzic who
tries to rob a bank in order to acquire
money for his partner sex change while
none of these acts jive with our general
collective morality we're still able to
empathize with and understand the
reasons behind each character's actions
but from the mid 70s and on largely due
to one mechanical shark in a certain
galaxy far far away Hollywood became
increasingly reliant on surefire
blockbusters and with some exceptions
has remained that way pretty much ever
since
in recent years that's meant an
increasing supply of IP driven content
specific
reliably successful comic book movies
most of those are inspired by
superheroes from the golden era of comic
books who typically represent moral
rectitude as a result these stories are
typically pretty black and white about
morality you have a hero and you have a
villain they Duke it out the hero wins
hooray
sure your spider-man or Iron Man might
make a mistake or learn a lesson or
overcome an unfortunate flaw and Nolan's
trilogy certainly shows its protagonists
grappling with some moral issues still
for the most part they're unlikely to
make an uber morally questionable choice
like Travis Rupert or Sonny this brings
us to Joker the first Hollywood film to
laser focus on the super villain
Phillips takes this big-budget
opportunity and uses it as a vehicle to
revive the 70s ethos of a complex
character in a doomed society turning
Arthur Fleck into a character that
obliterates our easy distinctions
between good and evil like many of these
70s anti-heroes Arthur is flawed complex
and to varying degrees sympathetic but
by subbing this 70s archetype into the
context of a comic book film Phillips
subverts the superhero genre and
challenges the typical simplicity of its
morality there's also another level of
subversion too Phillips is also using a
mainstream Hollywood film as a sneaky
vehicle for reviving the 70s that is the
last real golden era of independent
filmmaking before Hollywood became a
pipeline for big-budget action films and
hangover sequels he's dropping
mainstream studio dollar bills to depict
the challenging morality of these gritty
independent films and to reflexively
comment on and complicate the comic book
film genre pretty cool part - fantasy
versus reality one of Joker's defining
features is how it bends the distinction
between fantasy and reality this
thematic tension also appears in some of
our favorite 70s films most notably the
film's biggest inspirations Martin
Scorsese's films taxi driver and the
king of comedy many people have pointed
this out but Joker borrows copiously
from both films for example in Joker's
best homage to the king of comedy it
casts Robert DeNiro as a famous comedian
exactly like the one played by Jerry
Lewis opposite a young De Niro how do
you how do you do it I think it's that I
look at my whole life and I I see the
awful terrible things in my life
and turn it into something funny I just
happens but what about the first few
one-liners were they strong enough I was
a little strong enough no they were any
strong you'd hurt yourself that model is
you Debbie bastard like the king of
comedies Rupert
Arthur also has delusions of finding a
father figure in said famous comedian
and when rejected lashes out violently
and in Joker's best homage to taxi
driver it depicts Arthur as sharing
Travis's inordinate fascination with
guns in a delightfully dark touch Arthur
and his neighbor even mimic Travis's
iconic finger gun to the head possibly
as if to indicate that liked him neither
of them have anything to lose both taxi
driver and the King of Comedy feature
outcasts characters with pretty bleak
lives going through tough times only to
conclude with their greatest wildest
dreams realized Travis becomes a
celebrated hero precisely because of his
violence vigilantism and he gets hit on
by his dream girl to boot while Rupert
becomes a world famous comedian
precisely because he took another
comedian hostage these two outcomes are
improbable at best and completely
delusional at worst that's why both are
also frequently interpreted as being
pure fantasy in taxi driver
Travis kills multiple people with an
illegally purchased firearm and doesn't
go to jail but rather is valorized the
King of Comedy frequently transitions
into fantasy sequences and the
improbable ending could read like one of
those so despised Scorsese's occasional
protest we to read each film's
conclusion as the desperate imaginings
of a troubled character with only the
most tenuous grasp on reality but beyond
the superficial plot or character
references travis and rupert each emerge
as a remarkably appropriate blueprint
for a character like the Joker who is
notorious for lacking any semblance of a
stable reliable past we talk about the
Joker's ever shifting origin story
extensively in another wisecrack edition
but here's the too long didn't watch of
Joker's inscrutable past and Alan
Moore's The Killing Joke Joker's
portrayed as a failed comedian who had
one bad day that turned him very bad
later we learned that Joker isn't even
sure if that backstory is true
should make crafting his LinkedIn
profile particularly difficult in
contrast Christopher Nolan's Joker is a
pathological liar who seems to ad-lib
the truth for his own amusement most
intriguing comic writer Scott Snyder
gave us a joker who uses his mysterious
origins to manipulate those around him
fittingly this includes posing as a
psychiatric researcher working on his
own report which he fills with tragic
tales of childhood abuse I did my best
to help come up with the story you
wanted the one you needed the grim and
grimy tale of woe the one a publisher
would lay down six figures for viewed in
this light aligning Joker with the also
unreliable perspectives of a Travis
Bickle or Rupert Pupkin makes a lot of
sense it actually underscores the fact
that we could take the entire movie with
a grain of salt
in fact Joker could almost be read as
either a an imaginary Snyder style sob
story cooked up by the Joker himself all
in Arkham Asylum or be an imaginary
delusional tale of the Joker's rise to
folk hero much as Travis's newspaper
clippings or Rupert's memoir were for
them either way it gives this lasagna of
a film a whole extra layer but there's
another interesting aspect of the
fantasy reality dichotomy in all three
of these films the deep isolation of the
central character leads them to
fervently pursue the affection of a
beautiful inaccessible woman in the -
Scorsese films the men's ensuing
short-lived court ships are painted as
real and painfully awkward in Joker
Arthur also harbors an unrequited love
for his neighbor Sophie he takes her out
on a fun date and even get some after
committing his first murder psyche dude
imagine the whole thing a fact he
doesn't realize until he shows up
uninvited at an unsuspecting Sophie's
apartment a clarifying montage shows us
that unlike Travis or Rupert's fledgling
relationships Arthur's budding romance
existed only in his deeply troubled mind
the thing about all three of these women
is that they are the unlucky objects of
these three men's fantasies projections
of their desires to find love beauty and
a merciful end to their tragic isolation
except in Joker this romance is
literally imaginary as if well literal
izing the extent of these three men's
delusional projections in this way the
film seems to argue that no idealized
love story could save Arthur or Travis
or Rupert from their own rage pathology
and above all intolerable loneliness
part three media sensationalism this
brings us to another important theme
that Joker shares with many 70s films
that of media sensationalism now we
delve deeply into the influence the 1976
film Network had on Joker in our quick
take Joker and the politics of
recognition but network also reflects
rather presciently on the way
sensationalized media can completely
transform public perception in network
news anchor Howard Beale goes off the
rails and decries what he sees as a
deeply sick and broken society we know
things are bad worse than bad they're
crazy it's like everything everywhere is
going crazy so we don't go out anymore
then he threatens to commit suicide on
the air his crazed rants resonate deeply
all across America as people take to
their windows to scream at nobody in
particular
greedy news executives seeing the power
of Beals Angier continue to spotlight
him and plan even more sensational media
the film argues that people who are
emotionally and spiritually
disillusioned with a broken system can
be very easily swayed by the forces of
mass media which direct our attention to
whatever story is currently sexiest or
in our day
click iasts the ease with which Howard
attracts a fervent following suggests
that our desperation to find truth and
meaning can lead us dangerously astray
particularly when it's in the monetary
interest of TV executives what's more
Network shows the shrewd way the simple
act of widespread media coverage
effectively turns a very unstable Howard
into a martyr we're framing his
objectively concerning suicide
as a positive act of courage we see the
same effect at the ending of both taxi
driver and the King of Comedy whether
you read them as imaginary or real
Travis's celebrated status as a hero
suggests the power of the media to
reframe a society's moral outlook while
Rupert's post crime rise to celebrity
suggests that a media spectacle can as
with Howard turn any audacious Act into
something
worth celebrating similarly Dog Day
Afternoon shows the way in opportunistic
media will gladly transform someone like
Sonny and Adil bank robber into a folk
hero for a compliant thrill-seeking
public joker similarly features no
shortage of commentary on media
sensationalism after Arthur kills three
wealthy Wayne employees the media
transforms the anonymous clown into a
figurehead for Gotham's impoverished
masses a natural opponent of the revered
Thomas Wayne excessive and sensational
media attention bloats the importance of
Arthur's act turning him like sunny and
Travis and Rupert and Howard from mere
criminal or madman into a folk hero as
in the other films the masses comply and
Arthur becomes the unwitting leader of a
political movement he doesn't care about
Arthur's political apathy underscores
the arbitrary nature of mob mentality
and just how beholdin we are to the
choices the media makes about its
coverage though the film is set in a
Gotham akin to an early 80's New York
City Joker shrewdly adapts the themes of
these films for the intensified media
climate of our day today's internet hive
mind can conjure literal mobs to storm
top-secret government facilities or dunk
on children or mourn the passing of the
world's most dignified gorilla
similarly the fervor for which Arthur's
actions are covered by the media
effectively makes him like Harambee a
folk hero the violent mob that coalesce
is around him projects their own rage
onto his violent act and view it as a
call to arms media spectacle the film
tells us distorts the truth and
misdirects our emotions there are those
who would argue that just as media
attention valorizes Arthur flex actions
for the people of Gotham it does the
very same thing for real world audiences
uniting them behind a violent dangerous
symbol of the mocked and disenfranchised
that's why no discussion of Joker is
complete without mentioning the
requisite media controversy that
surrounded its release accusations that
the film would encourage violence or
validate dark audience impulses were
widespread perhaps fittingly both of its
two main inspirations
taxi driver and the King of Comedy also
experience their own varying degrees of
backlash taxi driver had to make some
edits to its climactic scene in order to
by with an r-rating and was partially
blamed for motivating an assassination
attempt on president reagan the king of
comedy also had its share of naysayers
with comedian Johnny Carson turning down
the role of Jerry Langford out of fear
of life imitating art and a healthy
supply of negative reviews reiterated
his point this isn't surprising films
that basically forced us to empathize
with characters like Travis Bickle or
Rupert Pupkin or Arthur Fleck characters
who make us grapple with morality
reality in probably some other a letís
that we don't have time to get into are
always going to be a lightning rod for
controversy ultimately though we think
the way that Joker thematically
incorporated its own controversial
cinematic forefathers is worth
mentioning and pretty cool but what do
you guys think is Joker an effective
callback to 70s greatness or a blatant
ripoff wearing a clown mask let us know
in the comments thanks again to our
incredible patrons for supporting the
podcast and the channel go ahead and
click that subscribe button and as
always thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]